sur les douches j'ai restreint une
douche tous les deux jours
toi tu prends une douche tous les jours
sur deux il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
quand je rentre je ne tire plus la
chasse d'eau
qui doit avoir
m'étonne que pas tous sans déconner
c'est vrai par exemple quand je fais
pipi j'attends 3 fois de faire pipi pour
tirer la chasse d'eau voilà c'est normal
mais j'espère que tout le monde en fait
tu es pas écolo tu es sale
[Applaudissements]
exactement tu sais faire des très belles
choses en 3 minutes
j'irai vraiment vous prenez une douche
tous les jours une douche presque enfin
très très fraîche tous les jours où
excusez-moi mais moi je fais des gros
trucs mais c'est pas voilà
si je fais des gros trucs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais pris l'avion de ma vie je
n'ai pas de permis de conduire donc je
n'ai jamais pris une voiture de ma vie
je n'ai pas de machine à laver je n'ai
pas de sèche-linge j'avais même pas que
ça existait
des boules
c'est bon non mais moi Guillaume et
Guillaume et Mathieu c'est Raymond avec
son camion
je fais 80000 km par an et en plus je
roule en camion c'est moi loin devant
vous avez je pollu énormément
tout le monde dans la coupe mais bien
sûr on prend les poubelles et vous allez
mettre les poubelles et bien sûr tu as
mis hein moi aussi je vais vous
descendez les poubelles de la salle de
bain dans la cuisine vous avez un local
à la poubelle et c'est quoi le tri des
trois poubelles c'est quoi les trois
c'est quoi le problème il y en a trois
c'est quoi
les papiers
c'est tout ce qui est légumes
[Rires]
non mais les gars j'ai jamais fait à
manger de ma vie bah oui tu crois
vraiment que je m'as déjà vu tu vois je
suis rentré je fais que commander moi je
mange que des pizzas et des pâtes
je le prends comme ça sur la tête de ma
mère je le pique comme ça je le prends
je le sais comme ça et je le mets dans
ma chapeau
je te jure je prends le carton je le
pire et après comme ça que je sors il y
a des tapis même quand même vous
cuisiner chez vous le soir
je mange que des pizzas ou des pâtes
pourtant vous êtes magnifique merci
bien ah oui toujours
[Applaudissements]
elle elle est comme une folle sur cette
balle merci oui qu'est-ce qui se passe
les gens très riches maintenant passent
de yacht au voilier c'est la
Grande-Motte
mais pourquoi tu nous dis ça parce que
ça vous intéresse de passer de passer
c'est bien mais pour l'économie
juste est-ce que vous en voulez aux gens
autour de la table de ne pas être assez
écolo dans son chariot vous croyez qu'on
peut encore sauver la planète
moi je pense que nos enfants nous
aideront nous c'est fini parce que quand
vous les regardez ils comprennent rien
ils font rien mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
il faut rien moi j'essaye chaque geste
est utile et nos enfants ils sont
éduqués pour ça mais ce que je comprends
pas c'est par exemple vous n'allez pas
voir les poubelles des voisins pour
savoir s'ils ont bien jeté les trains
je découvre des choses dingue qu'un jour
tu te fasses pas défoncer la gueule
parce que moi je te le dis moi mes
voisins me font ça si vous voulez je
viens et ce très beau poubelles après
tu vas fermer ta gueule tu vas ranger et
quand tu vois en Afrique en vacances tu
vas pas en bateau il va comment je suis
pas un exemple absolu mais alors ferme
ta gueule je fais tout pour qu'est-ce
que tu as dit
[Applaudissements]
ne pas tirer la chasse d'eau
systématiquement
trier les poubelles en plus pour les
gens qui les ramassent assez fondamental
et ne jamais rien jeter par terre par
terre dans Paris les mégots tout ça faut
arrêter les papiers faut arrêter ça
c'est essentiel pour tous les éboueurs
je les aime beaucoup qui font ça il faut
vraiment les aider
un jour ce que j'ai fait bien sûr j'ai
fait un truc genre de beau gosse c'est à
dire j'avais prévu un bail j'étais avec
des copains qui me suivaient en voiture
et je vais chercher une meuf j'avais
c'était la première fois je venais je
venais d'avoir le permis j'avais 18 ans
donc je prends la voiture ma mère et je
vais chercher une meuf en voiture elle
monte et tout et j'avais mis un pull et
genre pour faire le beau gosse je suis
dans la voiture avant je fais comme ça
on a un feu je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'enlève ma ceinture je fais [ __ ] j'ai
chaud comme ça je prends le pull et je
le jette par la fenêtre
[Rires]
mais en fait j'avais un pote derrière
qui est venu récupérer
un écorce un écorce avec toi après avec
mon slip voilà je vous le dis